[Music]
should know a bit about economics and
management now we'll have the reverse
side and learn perhaps what those in
economics and management should know
about technology professor Lester Thurow
I think I'm the first person today who's
on this platform that's neither a
chemist nor a chemical engineer and
since I'm the only non chemist or non
chemical engineer let me say happy
birthday for those of us from the rest
of the Institute chemical engineering is
clearly one of the crown jewels at MIT
and the rest of us at MIT appreciated
sexists now ralph said that in 1981 he
decided to give up being a chemical
engineer and become an economist and I
should warn him that he's going from a
high prestige occupation to a low
prestige occupation and it's solos blows
prestige I must tell you something about
the space agency when the space agency
had to go from the Challenger to the
discovery they decided that in doing
their experiments they would replace the
rats with economist and they announced
that there were three reasons why they
were placing rats with economist the
first reason was that they're now more
economists and they're cheaper than rats
the second reason is you sometimes get
emotionally attached to rats
and the third reason is there are some
things that rats just won't do
[Applause]
now people often ask me as economics of
science I think economics is a science
in exactly the same sense that geology
is a science which is a little different
than chemical engineering in that you
can't do experiments for example
geologists perfectly understand
earthquakes and volcanoes
it's called plate tectonics but they
can't predict when the next earthquake
will occur and how big it will be and I
think you have exactly that same problem
in economics we understand the
fundamental forces the plate tectonics
but we have a hard time when it comes to
timing and magnitudes because we can't
go into the laboratory and simulate
those kind of things but if you look at
the world around us at the moment there
is one fundamental force from the
economics of plate tectonics which is
going to affect us all in a specialty
Chemical Engineering and that is you can
think of those of us who have lived in
the United States is basically living
behind the Great Wall of China
economically speaking that kept the
barbarians out our wall was based on
five things after World War two we were
wealthy and they were poor so we could
afford to do things they couldn't afford
to do because we had invented mass
public education of mass higher
education first we had a better educated
workforce than they had because we
weren't blown up in World War two and
because the Europeans had given us some
of their very best brains like Einstein
we had superior technology we had the
world's biggest market by a factor of
seven and perhaps we had the world's
best managers and if you put all of
those things together we in the United
States we're not in a competitive world
we had effortless economic and
technological superiority the problem of
course and it's a problem based on
success not failure is the Great Wall of
China the economic Great Wall of China
has melted today we are no longer
wealthier than they are if you look at
international purchasing power there are
nine countries in the world there eight
countries in the world that have a
higher per capita GNP in the United
States not counting the chic tips
Austria Switzerland the Netherlands West
Germany Denmark Norway Sweden and Japan
all have in terms
of international purchasing power higher
per capita GNP the United States and
since they saved more than we do they
can afford things that we don't seem to
be able to afford in terms of a capital
equipment where we once had the world's
best educated labor force they've caught
up in in many cases surpassed this if
you look at college education about 30
percent of Japan Germany and the United
States go to college in this day and age
but in both Japan and Germany about 40
percent come out in engineering in
science and the United States a little
less than 20 percent come out in
engineering in science which means for
every one engineer on American payrolls
there going to be two engineers on
German and Japanese payrolls and we
shouldn't regard it as a surprise then
that perhaps their products are a little
bit better engineered because they're
putting twice as much talent into it in
terms of market size in 1992 the United
States becomes triple a ball Europe
becomes the economic big leagues with
integration 320 million people with a
per capita income approximately equal of
the United States
it'll be about 25 percent bigger than
the United States has an integrated
market and perhaps our managers are no
longer as good as those in the rest of
the world the buzzword in economics is
managers are change agents well if
that's the name of the game you major
change in terms of how fast is
productivity growing and productivity in
the United States is growing somewhat
slower than it is in the rest of the
industrial world and particularly slower
than it is in Germany and Japan which
would be some indication that perhaps
our managers have also melted in terms
of this superiority and so the fact of
the matter is the walls are down and in
some sense Genghis Khan is waiting where
the walls used to be and the name of the
game of course is can we change because
what we said to ourselves after World
War two and it may have been a lie but
we said it what we said was we wanted to
live in a world of other equally wealthy
people and the problem of living in a
world with other ether equally wealthy
people as that means they really are
your equals and they really are
competitive and you're sometimes envious
and I think we have all of those
problems at their moment now if you
think about the chemical industry it's a
relatively bright spot in the American
economy despite its problems over the
last 10 years productivity in the
American economy has grown into about
0.8 percent a year a little less than
one percent and that's what it grew in
1987 Manufacturing is better than the
national average it's been growing at
about three but productivity and the
chemically related industries have been
doing even better I looked up the
productivity growth rate into three
major ones for the last four years if
you take chemical products productivity
has been growing at about four point six
percent a year if you take petroleum and
coal products patrol productivity has
been growing at seven point three
percent a year and if you take rubber
and plastics productivity has been
growing at four point two percent a year
and as was mentioned in terms of export
performance chemicals is one of the few
industries along with aircraft that
still has a positive trade balance and
in 1987 our exports of chemicals rose
19% while our exports of all products
across the American economy are only
rising 12% and so in this sense your
industry is one of the better performers
in the American economy that doesn't
mean it's performing as well as it auto
but it means it's one of the better
performance and a question I want to
investigate today is what can we learn
from its successes is there anything out
there to learn and I think there is
something to learn and the purpose of
learning about looking at other
countries is not to do what they do but
basically to use them as a mirror to see
what you do not to adopt what they do
but to say if they've learned how to do
X we have to learn how to do X in a way
that is consistent with American history
culture and tradition for example take
the Olympics think about it 17 million
East Germans win more medals than 245
million Americans now we don't want to
Train athletes the way the East Germans
do it but what the East Germans tell us
is you can't do it the old American Way
because if you do it the old American
Way you won't win and therefore you have
to find a new way to train athletes that
consistent with American history
American culture American trade
that lets your athletes run as fast as
those in East Germany even though you
don't want to do it the East German way
because the East Germans set the
standards even though they don't tell
you how to do it and I think that's what
the rest of the world does for us
economically we can't do it as the
Japanese do what we can't do it as the
Germans do it
but we have to do it nonetheless if you
look at American industry and say well
why is it that American firms have had
so much trouble international
competitiveness I think you find a whole
set of events and you have to ask
yourself what causes these events one of
the things that is clearly true is in
the last couple of decades American
referr have been very reluctant to make
major bets on technology the kind of
bets that cost you a billion bucks to
make a dramatic example would be oxygen
furnaces where we built our first oxygen
furnace in America seven years after the
rest of the world built their first
auction furnace now if you ask why I
think there was an answer the basic
answer was this was a billion dollar bet
maybe even a two billion dollar bet in
today's dollars and the people at the
top of the industry were not on top of
the technology it was a black box as far
as they're concerned and the buzzword
was higher the expert you don't need to
be in charge on top of the technology
yourself but who's gonna bet a billion
dollars on a black box even if the
expert tells you to bet I think the
answer is nobody and so what you're
gonna do is you're going to sit there
and wait until the numbers are clear but
by the time the numbers are clear the
other guy spent three years building his
mill and three years operating his mill
and you're seven years behind in that
kind of thing and if you look at the
technological background of CEOs of
Fortune 500 equivalent companies you see
a very interesting difference between
the United States in either Germany or
Japan in the United States about 30
percent of our chief executives have
technological backgrounds and 70% do not
in Japan and Germany it's exactly the
opposite 70% do and 30% do not now the
interesting thing of course about the
chemical and chemical engineering
industry is it's one of the few
industries in the United States in fact
in which technological people tend to
come
the top the other day I saw a survey of
CEOs who had PhDs write a large number
of them in America but they're almost
all in either pharmaceuticals or
chemistry outside of pharmaceuticals in
chemistry you almost never find chemical
industries you almost never find a PhD
heading a company and I would at least
suggest that maybe that's one of the
reasons why this industry is a
relatively good performer secondly if
you look at technology you tend to find
that American firms are still pretty
good when it comes to product technology
recently a group of Europeans truck
divided all of science and engineering
into nine categories tried to figure out
who was the leader in each of the nine
categories and they this was kind of
product technologies and they came to
the conclusion that Americans were
leaders in five industries tied for
number one in two industries and number
two in two industries now if you have
five first two ties and two seconds
you're obviously number one in the world
there was something different the
difference of course was that our gap
between ourselves and the number two
wasn't as big as it used to be and the
other interesting difference of course
was that there was a definite number to
every place we were number one Japan was
number two every place we were tied for
number one it was with Japan and every
place where we were number two they were
number one and so for the first time in
our history there is a competitor on the
playing field that is identifiable the
Japanese if however you look at process
technologies it is difficult to find
places where American industry is
world-class in terms of quality or
productivity and once again the chemical
engineering industries is one of the few
exceptions where you can really find
first-class process technologies in
existence in American firms for example
the yield rates on semiconductor chips
the best American firms can't get the
same yield rates as the best Japanese
firms on those processed technologies
they're closing the gap but they're not
yet there I think there's an answer to
that my impression is that in chemical
engineering operations the way they're
set up you can't make this sharp
distinction between product and process
that people make in the rest of the
world
and that sharp distinction has become a
distinction in most of American industry
between first-class operations and
second-class operations the people who
do product technologies are first-class
brains the people who do process
technologies are second class brains and
you see that right across American
industry if you look at pay promotion
curves routes to the top in most of
American industry production is not the
way to the top it in fact is a dead end
not too long ago Fortune magazine asked
the CEOs of large companies what's the
route to the top in your industry how
many of those CEOs do you think said
production well five percent said
production 34% said marketing 25% said
finance and twenty four percent said
general management now my graduates if
the management school read those
statistics and if you read those
statistics would you ever go into
production of course you wouldn't
because it's only the place that stupid
people go who don't know the real facts
about life and how do you get to the top
of the heap and because of the nature of
this industry I think I would suspect
that if you ask that question inside the
chemical industries you wouldn't get
exactly those proportions now as much
mentioned one of the things we're trying
to do at MIT is do a little bit of
reversing of that because we think we're
partly to blame and most of MIT for
treating process technologies and
process management as if it was a second
class activity and we have recently put
together this program called leaders in
manufacturing which is joint between the
engineering school in the management
school to try and turn out people that
are both interested in and first class
in doing both the management in
scientific aspects of process
technologies and I should say I think
that the engineering school really took
the leadership on that and got the
initiative going because when it first
got going at the beginning I think the
management school was dragging its feet
a little bit on that process because we
were still in this mode of thinking hey
you just hire the expert you don't have
to be on top of it yourself and I think
Jerry Wilson and his crowd should be
congratulated for pushing that program
through and we actually have our first
students here in June six months ago or
months ago who started on this process
we're all so busy trying to put
management into our master students in
engineering and a little bit of
technology into our students in
management because if you think about it
management schools have been very funny
in the past because they teach
accounting they teach finance they teach
marketing but they don't teach
management of Technology but in fact
even if you're in a service industry in
general you're going to be managing
technology so one of the things that you
have to think about is how do you make
process technologies into a first-class
activity and I think almost because of
the technology in the chemistry business
it wasn't possible to make processes a
second-class activity and the way in
which it was in much of the rest of
American industry another place where
you see a tremendous American problem is
basically on the skills and
technological training of the workforce
not the engineers but the workforce now
here's a place where I think the
chemical industry was lucky not smart it
was lucky simply because you don't hire
any people and therefore you can't have
a lot of it illiterate saan your payroll
if you're in a technology that really
requires people then you've got to worry
about the education of the average
person and if you look at American
workforce and compare it with the
workforce in Germany in Japan our
problems do not lie at the level of the
30% of the population that goes to
college they're about as good as the 30%
of the population goes to college
anywhere else in the world our problem
lies with the high school graduate who
does not go to college because if you
look at a 12th grade graduate in Germany
in Japan they are just far above the
performance of a 12th grade graduate in
the United States now because their high
school exams are so tough we catch up
during college because in the freshman
South year in college a Japanese student
in Japan does precisely zero and so by
the time you graduate from college we
have caught up but if you don't go to
college you never catch up and
increasingly technologies are moving in
directions where average production
workers have just got to have levels of
skills that they didn't have to have in
the past for example if you go to the
IBM semiconductor facility in Burlington
Vermont where they have 8,000 people
working you will find that they are busy
teaching all
their production workers algebra 1 and
algebra 2 why are they teaching em
algebra 1 in algebra 2 well to make 1
million by chip she got a new
statistical quality control to do
statistical quality control the workers
have got a know little operations
research to learn the operations
research they got a know little algebra
and so there is IBM busily teaching
algebra 1 and algebra 2 but I can
guarantee you of something Hitachi
is not teaching algebra 1 and algebra 2
because Hitachi knows that every
graduate from a Japanese high school
knows calculus much less algebra 1 in
algebra 2 and so this whole question of
investing in your workforce and having a
high skilled workforce is one of the
places where if you just look across the
board
you see systematic under investment in
the United States and I don't think you
think see it in the chemical industry
but for the reason I mentioned you don't
hire anybody and therefore you can't
invest in anybody if you look at R&D you
see a number of interesting differences
between ourselves and the rest of the
world and here again these differences
are smaller in the chemical industry if
you look at civilian Rd we're putting
about 1.7 1.8 percent of the G into GNP
into civilian R&D both Germany and Japan
are putting about 2.8 percent of the GNP
into civilian Rd so we're being outspent
by one percentage point unless you think
we're smarter than they are and I don't
that isn't viable in the long run now if
you add in military R&D we spend about
the same amount about 2.8 but either
it's because we're going into space and
the time lags are longer or we're going
into space and the applicability is less
in recent years it has been getting
harder and harder to find spin-offs from
military research into civilian research
people when you talk about spin-offs
instantly mentioned the Boeing 707 which
came from a modified military transport
plane but my god that was 30 years ago
1957 in recent years the great
innovations have spun into the military
not spun off the transistor was the
telephone labs and it's spun into the
military the semiconductor chips was
Texas Instruments and oil well drilling
firm and it's spun into the military the
small computer was I don't know maybe
Steve Jobs is back
and it's fun into the military but none
of these things were invented in the
military and then spun out into the
general economy and so one of the
problems we have is how do we organize a
society where we up in some sense the
research intensity of our efforts that's
partly a private problem in the chemical
industry as you've seen the data it's
almost all private money but on average
in the United States about half the
money comes from government and half the
money from private industry and both of
those pieces have to be brought up I
think to that world-class level now if
you look at our distribution of R&D and
I don't know how this would come out in
the chemical industries you see an
interesting pattern the National Science
Foundation divides industries into
high-tech industries milk medium tech
industries and low tech industries a
high tech industry is anyone that spends
more than twice the national average in
R&D as a fraction of sales a low tech
industry is any industries which spends
less than half the national average of
R&D relative to sales and middle tech is
obviously between one-half and two on
that basis America puts 88% of its
research money into high-tech activities
8% in the Middle tech activities and 4%
into low-tech activities the Japanese do
it almost precisely the opposite they
put 21% into high-tech activities 12%
into middle tech activities and 67% into
low-tech activities and what they are
doing is basically picking off those
industries which traditionally have
either not done any researcher have gone
out of the research business and making
them into relatively high tech
industries and getting a tremendous
competitive advantage out of doing it
for example automobiles is a low tech
industry traditionally automobiles have
put almost nothing into research and
development as a fraction of sales and
think about the innovations in
automobile since World War two the last
one that begun in the United States was
the automatic transmission in 1947 but
all the innovation since then have come
from abroad to the United States 4-wheel
steering four-wheel drive turbo charging
all of those things or things that
started abroad and came into the United
States
now interestingly Germany is halfway
between the United States and Japan when
it comes to spending its money on high
tech middle tech and low tech and one of
the things we need to think about is are
we spending our research money in the
appropriate way another place where
we're systematically different than the
rest of the world is how we divide our
money between new product R&D and
process Rd we put almost all of our
research money in the new product Rd and
very little into new process Rd I
suspect in the chemical industry that's
not true a good fraction of it still
goes into process R&D now the reason we
do that is the conventional wisdom in
the 50s and 60s was the rate of return
on investment is always higher on new
product R&D because if you invent a new
product you got a kind of a quasi
monopoly position for a little while and
you can earn more money and I think that
was probably true in the 50s and 60s but
it's obsolete in today's world economy
because simply inventing something isn't
good enough unless you're the lowest
cost person in the world at making that
something because anything you can
invent can be reverse engineered in six
months and if the other guy can make it
cheaper than you can make it he makes it
his product and a perfect example of
that was video recorders video recorders
were invented in America but we could
never get the production costs down low
enough to make them into a home product
the Japanese do that and they last year
made 38 million video recorders none
were made in the United States do you
know how many of those video recorders
were sold in Japan 6 million you no
matter how many of them were sold in the
United States 22 million an American
intervention but generating billions of
dollars worth of profits and hundreds of
thousands of jobs in Japan because we
weren't on top of the production
processes even though we were in the
inventor of the product and I think what
the world economy has done has changed
the nature of those IR eyes in American
industry hasn't yet rebalanced its
research portfolio to take into account
that modern reality if you're not the
lowest cost producer of a product it
doesn't do you any good to invent the
product and that's a reality that most
of American industry has yet
to encompass now the other part of this
world economy that we have to face of
course is the rest of the world's
different it isn't little Americans or
big Americans it's different and we have
to find a way to cope with those
differences and recognize those
differences let me just give you a
couple of differences for you to think
about on the way home
tomorrow in Japan they have the big
zaibatsu groups Mitsui Mitsubishi
Daiichi Congo group Fuji Group once a
month the companies in each of those
groups and there are 25 to 45 companies
in each group get together and the CEOs
have a meeting an all-day meeting
sometimes it's called the Thursday Club
sometimes it's the Tuesday club nobody
but the CEOs can ever go no substitutes
are allowed no outsiders are ever
allowed I have obviously never been to
one of those meetings but I know
precisely what they talk about what do
you think they talk about they talk
about joint strategy very important busy
people don't spend the day having Oreo
cookies all of those companies are in
the United States if you had that
meeting in the United States everyone
any of them would be thrown in jail
because that a meeting is against the
law in the United States but it's a fact
of life in the world economy now we may
not want to allow those commit kinds of
meetings in the United States we have no
way to stop those kind of meetings in
Japan but the question is given that
fact about the world economy how do we
organize ourselves I think one of the
things it means is that we're going to
have to learn both how to compete and
cooperate in order to compete American
companies are going to have to learn how
to cooperate with an in an industry in
terms of doing some of the research and
development together to cut costs and a
whole variety of cooperative things will
be required at the same time you want to
maintain competitiveness and we have to
find a way to do that one other example
mr. Honda 14 years ago decided he wanted
to quit being a motorcycle company and
as he told him
at that time he wanted to build the
biggest and best automobile company in
the world when he was a motorcycle
company he made a 9% rate of return on
his investments since he has decided to
become an automobile company
he has made a 3% rate of return on
investment but he doesn't regard that as
a bad performance
he just regards that it's the cost of
building the biggest and best automobile
company in the world what American
company could do that what American
company would do that well the answer if
is if none could or none would then
American companies will not be the
biggest and best in the automobile
industry and it's just that simple
because there's something in economics
which is technical jargon which is
called factor price equalisation but it
has a very simple bottom line the bottom
line is if you aren't smarter than a guy
on the rest of the world if you don't
have more capital than the guy on the
rest of the world if you don't have more
technology than the guy in the rest of
the world if you don't have better
management than the guy on the rest of
the world you will work for exactly the
wage he works for and so if you aren't
better on any of those things than the
Koreans are you will work for Korean
wages now American managers are like
that part of factor price equalisation
what they don't like is the other part
if a capitalist in Japan calls mr. Honda
will work for a three percent rate of
return then you will work for a three
percent rate of return unless you are
better than he is and it is very hard to
be better than he is because he may be
the world's best I was on a platform not
too long ago with lots of Chrysler as
the number three man at Chrysler and he
said Honda has the best productivity in
the world the best quality in the world
superior design but they don't make any
money and of course he didn't jump to
the bottom line if they don't make any
money
Chrysler won't make any money because he
had just admitted that Chrysler wasn't
better than Honda on any of those
dimensions and see that's the world
economy it's different and I think what
you have to think about inside the
chemical industries is even though
you're a relatively bright spot in the
American icon
how do you make yourself into a real
power in the world economy as opposed to
just a relatively bright spot in the
American economy and what the rest of
American industry has to say is first of
all how can we get up to the level that
the American chemical industry is
already at and then how can we also be
world-class performers because see if
you think about international
competition it has two downsides you
know on the 4th of July Americans like
to talk about competition and we always
make it sound like it's a positive but
in fact competition is not a positive on
two dimensions the first dimension upon
which competition is a negative
obviously as you can be beaten not one
year but every year the Chicago White
Sox have never won a pennant America may
become the Chicago White Sox and of
course the second part of it is if you
want to win you got to change thank you
thank you very much Lister for a very
enjoyable talk the next major thing on
our program will be the open house
just prior to ending the symposium we'll
have some closing remarks from ray ray
beador ray was the department head when
our new building which some of you may
never have seen before will have the
opportunity single in a while ray was
the department head when that was
planned and the money was raised and we
got it and it was the first building
ever built on campus explicitly for
chemical engineering so I'd like to
introduce ray we'll make a few closing
remarks
well this will be a real change of pace
from what you've been listening to these
are sort of private remarks to the
alumni and a thank you for what they've
done because the story of the chemical
engineering building is the story of how
our alumni came to our assistance when
we needed their help as they have so
many times before at the end of World
War two we inherited building 12 which
was constructed on campus for the Army's
chemical warfare service at the
instigation of Bradley Dewey
Bradley foresaw that the department
would be able to use this building as a
home when the war was over and which we
did for many years but by the mid
sixties we had outgrown the building and
the laboratories were inadequate for the
kind of research which we were doing we
had to have new quarters however when I
took over from Ed Gilliland as head of
the department in March of 1969 the
Vietnam inspired student unrest was in
full swing within a week after I took
the job some students had battered down
the door to the offices of the chairman
and president and occupied the suite all
academic building plans at the Institute
had been canceled and the campus had the
appearance of a place under siege
furthermore the department graduated
only twenty four seniors that year the
smallest class since the department
became independent of chemistry in 1920
this was the situation that the
Institute when I approached the
administration for authorization to
raise sixteen million dollars for a new
chemical engineering building which is
equivalent to about thirty five million
dollars today well they looked at me
like I was proposing to walk on water
and understandably so what they didn't
know was that I had a secret weapon we
weren't going to walk on water we were
going to run on oil and here is the
lineup that we had to do that Ken
Jamison chairman of Esso was chairman of
our
in committee and Ken had agreed to
support my proposal to the
administration and help by chair cherry
a sponsoring committee Bob Gunness was
president of Indiana and Bob is as loyal
and supportive and alumnus as we have
butch Grandville and alumnus of the
practice school was chairman of Texaco
Jerry McAfee was president of Gulf Wall
of Canada Bob Dorsey chairman of Gulf
oil was not an alumnus but Jamison
brought him on board before my very eyes
in an operation so smooth and painless
that poor dorcy dorcy didn't even know
what hit him
and there were standard of California
with George Keller prepared to carry the
data for us there
Dayton chloral at Mobile Dan Magee at
Kerr McGee and Bob Harbaugh at Sun Oil
in fact the oil industry responded
generously to our approaches as they had
to if we were to succeed and it was our
alumni in those industries who made the
success there are many interesting
stories to be told about this effort but
one will be enough to give you the
flavor of what our alumni did knowing
that the administration were too
preoccupied with unrest on the campus to
raise money for a chemical engineering
building
I took Jerry Wiesner to joist chins for
lunch and while he was preoccupied with
egg rolls I asked him if I would be
permitted to raise the money for our
building myself
Jerry's response was that no department
had ever done this before but why not I
had my first support by the time the
campaign began two years later Howard
Johnson had become chairman at the
Institute and agreed to work with me on
the fundraising but we needed a
sympathetic audience to practice on to
perfect our presentation since this kind
of major fundraising was new to us bob
Gunness agreed to arrange for us to make
our first pitch to Jon Swearengen then
chairman of Indiana
those of you who know Swearengen can
understand that this was like letting
Red Sox warm-up by playing the New York
Mets I can give you an idea of how that
first attempt came off by telling you
that compared with the job that we did
before Swearengen dan quayle would seem
like a professional debater but gun is
saved Indiana force we polished up our
act and went on to set the following new
records for the Institute first ours was
the first successful building fund
campaign led by the department head
himself second ours was the first
academic building funded entirely from
private sources since George Eastman
financed the construction of the
Cambridge campus no government money
third ours was a pace setting campaign
averaging two million dollars a month
for most of the funding fourth our
alumni topped it off with two privately
funded chairs
the Edwin R Gilliland's here led by Paul
Cook and the Willard out share led by
herb Dowd in announcing these two chairs
at the dedication of the new building
Howard Johnson stated that this was a
first for the Institute of course there
were a large number of alumni who
contribute to these successes but these
are the ones with whom I work directly
the succession of visiting committee
chairman Ken Jameson Bob gunas John
Haase and especially Ralph Landau who's
named the building carries and who has
long been active in almost every aspect
of the department's affairs we are all
grateful to you alumni who have
supported us for so long in so many ways
but when you visit the new building you
will also see new people there are many
here of my vintage who remember the
department as Doc Lewis bill McAdams ed
Gilliland Ernie Hauser
Hoyt Hottel fritz Meisner Harold Weber
Tom Sherwood and Walter Whitman now we
have a new department
on this point I will close by telling
you a story
that Tom Sherwood told me when I was
bemoaning the loss of the old guard when
Thomas in high school his school
football team won the division
championship but the football team were
all seniors and graduated together the
whole school was worried because they
would have to field a brand new team the
next year when Tom was telling me this
story he looked at me and smiled and do
you know what happened they won the
championship I can still hear Tom
laughing thank you for coming enjoy your
visit
[Applause]